today on the matt wells show jesse
smellet has been found guilty of
committing a hate crime hoax but i think
a hate crime hoax is a hate crime in
itself and should be charged as such
we'll talk about that today speaking of
hate crimes my best-selling lgbt
children's book johnny the walrus has
been removed from amazon's lgbt list
i'll have something to say about that
today and a fair warning uh i might get
a little emotional about it because i'm
pretty upset also a male college swimmer
is dominating female swimming outkick
has an interview with one of his
teammates and she is not happy plus
simone biles is named athlete of the
year for quitting we'll talk about that
and so much more today on the matt wall
show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know that one out of three americans
regularly suffer from nausea i know i'm
one of them and for me it's you know sit
in the backseat of a car of an uber or
something like that especially if i'm
looking at my phone which even makes it
worse but um nausea what it could do i
know this from experience it can ruin
your day and it can force you to change
your plans and the most severe cases it
can make us unable to function
uh if you can relate then i've got good
news it's called relief bend you've got
to check out relief relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangover morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the product is 100
percent drug free it's also non-drowsy
unlike some of the pills that you can
buy for
especially if you're you know for motion
sickness and that kind of thing a lot of
those will make you drowsy and uh that's
not the case with relief ben it also
provides an all-natural long-lasting
relief with zero side effects for as
long as needed so you've got to try
relief band don't let nausea get in the
way of your life anymore as the holiday
season quickly approaches there's never
been a better time to give the gift of
relief and make sure your loved ones are
nausea free right now relief ban has an
exclusive offer just for my listeners if
you go to reliefband.com and use promo
code walsh you'll receive 20 off plus
free shipping and a no questions asked
30-day money-back guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code walsh for
20 off plus free shipping it should not
really be a surprise that con artist and
now convicted felon jesse smallett was
found guilty of committing a race hoax
the evidence against him was
overwhelming
you know they say that absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence but
in the case of a hate crime hoax that's
often not true if smolet was really
accosted and assaulted by a roaming gang
of militant bleach-wielding white
supremacists there would have been lots
of positive evidence to support that
claim the fact that there was no such
evidence was reason enough to conclude
that the claim was a fabrication that
along with the fact that the story was
absurd and implausible and ludicrous on
its face on every level
except in this case there was not only
absence of evidence to support his
version of events but positive evidence
disproving it since his co-conspirators
admitted their role in the plot and
produced documentation to show that
there was a plot
all of this to say
there should not have been any suspense
a guilty verdict should have been a
foregone conclusion but as the jury
failed to reach a verdict somehow on the
first day of deliberation and the hours
ticked by during the second day it
started to seem quite possible that they
would maybe come back with an acquittal
justice mullet's defense team certainly
didn't do anything to convince them of
his innocence but
they played the victim card constantly
reminding the jury that smilet is a gay
black man that indeed was their whole
defense that he's a gay black man
um the victim card shouldn't be worth
anything at all especially in court and
especially when it's played by a wealthy
actor but in our country today it can
unlock many doors
and get you out of many jams and it
could well have done that here yet it
didn't the justice system actually
worked and not for the first time in
recent weeks it's on a little bit of a
of a streak i guess
and jesse smallett was convicted on five
out of six counts yesterday he faces up
to 20 years in prison
and should serve every day of it
although i expect he'll probably just be
given a slap on the wrist a few hours of
community service and we'll get back to
this issue of the appropriate punishment
for his crime in just a moment but first
it's worth recalling
what the left said about the smollette
case when the story was first reported
by a credulous media
now when i say the left i mean not just
random accounts on twitter but the most
prominent and powerful individuals in
that camp joe biden at the time tweeted
what happened today to jesse smollett
must never be tolerated in this country
we must stand up and demand that we no
longer give this hate safe harbor that
homophobia and racism have no place on
our streets or in our hearts we are with
you jesse
notice there's no alleged no words like
claim or reportedly being used
just an outright acceptance of the story
in its entirety without a hint of
skepticism
same for camilla harris who said at the
time
jesse smolet is one of the kindest most
gentle human beings i know i'm praying
for his quick recovery
this was an attempted modern day
lynching
no one should have to fear for their
life because of their sexuality or color
of their skin we must confront this hate
an attempted modern day lynching
it wasn't much of an attempt considering
the assailants gently placed the rope
around his neck and then ran away 30
seconds later according to him
so that's like trying to shoot somebody
by throwing the bullet at their head
but that kind of critical thinking is
not allowed when a member of a protected
class makes a claim of this sort
which is why every major leftist in the
country rallied around jesse
the daily mail takes us farther down
memory lane they report
uh going back to 2019
other liberal stars whose pro-jesse
tweets have now aged very poorly include
democratic representatives and squad
members alexandra caser cortez as well
as rashida to leap
aoc at the time tweeted there is no such
thing as racially charged this attack
was not possibly homophobic it was a
racist and homophobic attack
if you don't like what if you don't like
what is happening to our country then
work to change it it is no one's job to
water down or sugarcoat the rise of hate
crimes
and then talib said when one of the most
famous black and gay men in america is
not safe the message is clearer than
it's ever been
uh the dangerous lies spewing from the
right wing is killing and hurting our
people thinking of you justice millet
and my lgbtq neighbors
other top democrats who rallied against
the now debunked beating include house
speaker nancy pelosi in vermont senator
uh bernie sanders pelosi soapboxed the
racist homophobic attack on justice
millet is an affront to our humanity no
one should be attacked for who they are
or whom they love
she's right though
no one should
and thankfully no one was
but out of all the famous leftists who
used the smilet hoax as an opportunity
to prove their woke bona fides
none could top ellen page who
back when she was ellen page went on
stephen colbert's late night show and
tearfully blamed mike pence
for the fact that jesse smallett
attacked himself
now in retrospect
not even retrospect but even at the time
this is maybe the funniest segment
stephen colbert has ever aired and it
was unintentionally funny let's uh let's
go back and watch a little bit of this
again
i'm like really fired up tonight this is
how this is how you have to be fired it
feels impossible to not feel this way
right now with the president and the
vice president mike pence who like
wishes i couldn't be married let's just
be clear
the vice president of america wishes i
didn't have the love with my wife
he wanted to ban that in indiana
he believes in conversion therapy
[Music]
he has hurt lgbtq people so badly as the
government of indiana and i think the
thing we need to know and i hope my show
gaycation did this in terms of
connecting the dots in terms of what
happened the other day to josie i don't
know him personally i saw i sent all of
my love
connect the dots
this is what happens
if you are in a position of power and
you hate people
and you want to cause suffering to them
you go through the trouble you spend
your career trying to cause suffering
what do you think is gonna happen
kids are gonna be abused and they're
gonna kill themselves and people are
gonna be beaten on the street
i have traveled the world and i have met
the most marginalized people you can
meet
i am lucky to have this time and the
privilege to say this
this needs to stop
so powerful so sincere i mean she
literally sounds like she's reading a
script
she's met the the most marginalized
people
like you know hollywood actors
very marginalized
how does this work by the way because
ellen page is a man now she says so her
relationship with her wife is actually a
heterosexual marriage
you know however however that works i
don't know
we know um that ellen page
was a privileged white male mansplaining
about the jessie smilet case
and of course everything she said was
wrong
we have to understand about ellen page
and joe biden and camilla harris and all
the rest of them is that they all of
course knew that the hoax was a hoax at
least they knew that it very well may
have been
but in their minds even if it wasn't
true
it was still true on some deeper more
ambiguous level
you know if justice millet wasn't a
victim of two white guys in in maga hats
in chicago at 2 a.m in january he was
still a victim in general as far as they
were concerned
not only that but but he was by virtue
of his identity a victim of white guys
and bag-a-hats
none of them have to actually attack him
or
do anything to him or or even say
anything to him
to victimize him
they victimize him by existing and he is
victimized and he is victimized by
existing
this is the tortured thought process of
a leftist
and it's how they justify elevating and
amplifying and demanding that we believe
every race hoax that has ever been
concocted
because even if it's not true it's still
true
what was that phrase from uh from
alexandria case or cortez
you know something could be factually
wrong but morally correct or something
like that
and that's how they look at it
they've decided ahead of time who the
villains are and who the heroes are
the details of any individual case are
irrelevant
and even if it ends up not being true
technically speaking by amplify
amplifying it they still succeed in
reinforcing their victim narrative and
driving a wedge between the races which
is their true intention
that's also why going back to jesse's
punishment
um
in a truly just country
i know i said our justice system is
working but
maybe we could say in these few cases
it's worked as well as we can expect
but if it really worked
justice millett ought to be charged with
a hate crime himself
you know just like we if you if you
falsely claim that someone raped you
and it's proven that it was a false
claim
then you should get the penalty that
they would have gotten
had they been convicted based on your
false claims
and so if you if you claim a hate crime
and it didn't happen
then you should be charged with a hate
crime yourself
now the hate crime category is
intentionally
vague and arbitrary and shouldn't exist
you could argue that almost all crime is
motivated by hate on some level
or most of it
or worse by indifference
i mean who's to say that crimes driven
by hate are worse than crimes driven by
indifference to human life most school
shootings fall into this latter category
maybe not so much hate as just total
indifference to human life
much of the violence that we see in our
cities is is motivated by total
indifference to human life
is that is that is that better than
being motivated by hate
and who's to say which sort of hate is
worse than other kinds of hate
the whole category again should not
exist but since it does
it ought to be used here against justice
milan
because we should be clear about what
this was
it was not just a hoax or a scam and it
was both of those things
but it was also an anti-white hate crime
now remember hate crimes do not need to
be targeted at any individual single
person
so if you hang a noose on a tree as a
threat to black people in general you'll
be charged with a hate crime of course
as it happens every news on a tree story
ends up being a hoax or somebody
misinterpreted a tire swing or something
but if ever there is a real case if that
ever actually happens
it will be a hate crime
and be charged that way even if there is
no one specific individual victim
so justice millett's hoax was an attack
on white people
in general white conservatives
especially
it was meant to stir up hatred and
resentment towards that group he had
other motivations as well
you know this was this was also a ploy
in contract negotiations
as it turns out you know maybe the worst
contract negotiating technique ever
employed by anybody
but
on top of that he had ideological and
and other kinds of motivations
and one of them was
anti-white
it was meant to reinforce the worst
stereotypes about white people white men
white conservatives
and i have no doubt you know that if if
two random white saps had made the
unfortunate mistake of walking somewhere
nearby on that night in chicago
and the police suspected them of the
crime because they happened to be caught
on security cameras walking nearby or
something smallett would have had no
problem
sending them to prison for 40 years to
pay for a crime that he made up
i have no doubt about that
that's the other thing about about a
hoax hate crime
is that you're you're throwing this out
there
this grenade you're pulling the pin on
the grenade and throwing it out there
and uh if it explodes and takes some
innocent person out
that's that's your fault and you
apparently have no problem with that
that's why you're doing it
so if there was if there was real
justice in the in this country
you know if someone had actually done
that to justice millet
uh and it wasn't his nigerian friends
but if there were two if that story
somehow in some bizarro world was true
what what penalty would those
attackers be facing
i'm thinking 40 to 50 years in prison
probably if not more that's what justice
millet should do
because this was a hate crime
itself
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well this doesn't happen to me very
often but the prompt i'm giving here is
to tell you that it's a lot of fun when
you're invited to join something that
you know when you're when you're given
an invitation to join something i don't
get invited to a lot of stuff because
nobody likes me but uh if you've
experienced that you know how fun it is
and if you're looking for a job or
hoping to get a better one that's how
you could feel when you use ziprecruiter
ziprecruiter has switched up the job
search game you can actually hear from
employers who want you before you even
apply when you create a free profile on
zipr.com they act like your free
personal recruiter zip recruiter pitches
your profile to employers whose jobs
match your experience so rather than
taking the passive approach of just
going and googling or whatever
this is this is something where it's
active they're gonna go out they're
gonna pitch you they're gonna find
employers for you if someone from that
company really likes what they see they
can personally invite you to apply to
their job the best part is that
recruiters invite to apply makes you
feel confident about applying for that
job because you know that the employer
is already interested in uh in your
services potentially so you have some
idea where you stand no wonder zip
recruiter is the number one rated job
site by g2 so today i'm inviting you
listener to try zip recruiter for free
just sign up on ziprecruiter.com
easy once again go to zip recruiter.com
easy right now to sign up absolutely
free and put zip recruiter to work for
you
let's uh begin with a report from
outkick about the trans swimmer at
university of pennsylvania a dude who
raced against other dudes for three
years and then decided in his fourth
year
that uh that he's a woman
and outkick was able to speak
anonymously because she didn't you know
for probably obvious reasons she didn't
want to be identified
they were able to speak anonymously to
one of his uh one of this guy's now
teammates female teammates
and she is uh not happy and she says
that nobody on the team is happy
but they can't say that out loud
so let's read now from outkick it says
first a little bit of the context while
university of pennsylvania transgender
swimmer leah thomas who spent three
years at the ivy league school swimming
as a male has been busy smashing female
pool records friction has been building
within the team according to a penn
female swimmer who said that she feared
for her ability to find employment after
graduating from college for sharing her
honest opinion about a transgender
teammate for that reason out kick is
granting her an anonymity to speak out
uh by the way this is written by joe
kinsey thomas's latest round of a
swimming record destruction came at a
three-day meet in akron ohio where
numerous pool meet and program records
weren't just destroyed but lowered to a
point where they may never be broken
um and that means of course that
after
leah quote unquote thomas
is long gone
these records are going to stand there
and there's not going to be now there
should be an asterix at least saying oh
by the way this was a dude
and so that way future
female swimmers
if they want to go for the record they
know which record they have to beat
but now he's setting his records that
it's this is not just victimizing the
women that he's racing against in the
moment
all future women
because now he's he's taking these
records and he's putting them out of
reach
because he has a whole collection of
biological advantages that none of these
other women have
and it's not going to be on the record
book there's not going to be anything
signifying this
um
continues here it
in the six 1650
uh freestyle final thomas didn't just
win and set new program pool and meet
records it was total annihilation
um penn's anna kalandasi finished in
second place 38 seconds behind thomas
now i don't know if i need to tell you
this but 38 seconds
um in a race of this kind
is an enormous gap
enormous during a phone interview a
female pen swimmer we don't know her
name says pretty much everyone
individually has spoken to our coaches
about not liking this our coach
his name is mike schnur just really
likes winning he's like most coaches i
think secretly just knows it's the wrong
thing to do
now i can't get inside of mike schner's
head but uh i'm guessing that his
motivation for allowing this to happen
for going along with this farce
it might be partly that he likes winning
but i think it's even more
uh it's even more cowardice
you know
i think i think she does him a favor by
saying that the coach is going along
with this because of us because of this
over competitiveness or something
because he wants to win too much
that would be bad enough but that's not
as bad as the reality which is that uh
mike schner is almost certainly
humiliated and embarrassed by all of
this
i mean does he actually want to win
like this
with a dude racing against girls
i would say almost certainly no
but he's too afraid to say anything
she continues when the whole team is
together we have to be like oh my gosh
go leah that's great you're amazing it's
very fake
um
and and then she continues talking about
um talking about how nobody likes this
on the team but nobody they feel like
they can't say anything
and uh they think that if they say
something they're going to be
cast as transphobes and bigots and this
is going to affect them not just in
their social life not just at school but
going forward in um
in their professional lives as well
and they're probably right
now one of the ways that this is being
justified is that um
that thomas
has started taking hormone pills you
know he started the the transition
and so his testosterone levels have
dropped
and so that's supposed to mean that it's
perfectly perfectly fair for him to race
against the girls in that case
but alkick does a good job of you know
not just comparing
this guy's times to the other girls and
when you do that you see what an
absolute again what a farce this is that
he's just destroying them
they have no chance
but also they compare his times
uh racing against the women
to his times in his first three years
racing against men
and if the if the testosterone
suppression and all that kind of stuff
the pills that he's taking
if it made that big of a difference you
should see it in his times and what you
find instead like for example the 200
freestyle 200 meter freestyle um against
the women he's he swims a um a 140
basically 142 just about 142.
and when he was racing against the men
before he started taking the pills and
when he had more testosterone coursing
through him
he was he was at a 139.3
so he goes from 139.3 to a 141.9
that's a difference every second counts
but that still puts him
far above most other women
it makes a small difference
not a very big one and why why does it
make a very big difference well because
testosterone is not the only advantage
that men have
this is the the total absurdity
that the pro-trans people engage in
where they pretend
that the only difference between men and
women is testosterone
but of course even if that was true
by admitting that
you
you are admitting there's a difference
pretending that that's the only
difference still means that there is a
biological difference between the two if
trans women are women if there's no
difference between them
then why does the trans woman have to
take any pills at all
if they're exactly the same
the the quote-unquote trans woman
shouldn't have to take pills
so they're reducing all of the
difference between men and women they're
reducing it down to this one thing
hormones
and by doing that they're still
admitting
that their whole position is nonsensical
and wrong
but as always with the left when they're
when they're trying to justify
especially when it comes to gender
ideology
everything they say is so wrong and
there are so many levels of wrongness
that you you don't even know where to
start
and sometimes it's almost it's almost
overwhelming and intimidating to and
maybe this is one of the reasons why
people stay out of that stay away from
this issue the big reason is that
they're afraid
also it's just so incredibly wrong
that again you don't know where the
access point is
and if you make one argument
against this then you're neglecting
there there are 50 other really good
arguments you're neglecting
that's what the left does they they
overwhelm you with wrongness
they just drown you in it
speaking of swimming
so um
you know that's why even if hormones
were the only difference
that still is a difference which proves
that these are biologically distinct
categories of people right
um and putting all of that aside
it's still wrong
to have the males race against the
females because males are not females
okay if leah thomas was in the middle of
the pack against the females
or even losing
does that make it right
no
because he's not a female
okay that would just make him a really
really bad swimmer as a male
but we should also note that hormones
are not the only difference between men
and women
and this comes through especially in
swimming
you know the differences are
every part of us
i mean literally if you are a male every
part of you is male
right down to your dna which is why
when when you're dead and gone
and only your a rotted corpse remains
and they're not able to you know
test testosterone levels on you
they'll still be able to tell that
you're a male
if only a piece of you remains a hundred
years hence
and they dig you up they'll be able to
tell you're male because you are a male
down to your bones down to your cells
down to your dna
and
many of those differences i mean there
are dozens and dozens and dozens of
biological differences that i mean
really there are thousands of biological
differences between men and women
because again it goes right down to the
cells
but there are at least dozens of
differences that specifically give you
an advantage in something like swimming
but these uh even the one girl who will
speak out and honestly anonymously
she'll only do it anonymously
and i can i can understand that by the
way
and it is easy for me to say sitting
here especially as someone who gets paid
to talk about these issues and to say
controversial things
um so i'm not in the position that these
girls are in
but even so there is there is no hope
for any of this unless we are going to
be courageous and start and start
speaking the truth
emperor has no clothes it just you need
at least one person in the crowd to
stand up and say he has no clothes
and the whole point of that parable is
that it's an emperor
this is just some random citizen
pointing that out
not in a position of power
very much
susceptible and vulnerable
could be punished in who knows in in
many different ways
for embarrassing the emperor but
someone's got to do it
and and the thing is
the male intrusion into female sports
that could be stopped
tomorrow i mean that could be stopped
today that could be stopped immediately
if the girls on these teams refused to
participate
and said we're not do we're not going to
any matches we're not going any meets
we're not going any games whatever the
sport is
uh we're not going to participate
anymore until the males are gone
if all the girls said that or or even
half of them or even a sizeable minority
said that this is over this is done
so in fact we do have a lot of power as
the sane people in this country but we
have to we have to use it
that's what makes it so frustrating and
tragic
is that in fact um what's going on
especially with gender ideology
almost everyone knows that it's wrong
almost everyone recognizes how
ridiculous it is and how harmful it is
and how unfair it is almost everyone
does
and we have the power to stop it because
we have numbers but we don't use the
power that we have
all right fox news is getting made fun
of because of their reaction to their
tree being burned uh which happened a
few days ago their big christmas tree
outside in uh in um
uh in times square burned by a homeless
guy who was immediately released on no
bail by the way despite starting a
massive fire in the middle of a city
and i think the tree was worth like half
a million dollars
but the left is accusing fox of kind of
milking the story i guess but here's how
fox and friends addressed it a couple
days ago
here's the thing in new york under the
new liberal policies of bail reform
arson is only a felony you can only be
held if it's a felony if the suspect
tries to harm a person or commits a hate
crime and apparently lighting a
christmas tree on fire is not a hate
crime but it is even though a lot of
people could have been injured yeah here
and but here's the thing who says not a
hate crime against us against fox news
uh here's the thing
what we do know for sure
and we don't know the guy's motivation
but the judge could ask and be under
suspicion and keep him locked up well he
might have but here's the here's what we
do know according to the new york post
which is co-owned with us that christmas
tree was half a million dollars i know
so this guy tortures a half a million
dollars worth of property and he gets to
walk
so the left is having fun with the fact
that brian kilmeade said that it's a
hate crime against fox news clearly he
was half kidding about that
but but overall fox's reaction to this
has been has been pretty reasonable i
think because i'm just imagining like
think about if this happened to cnn
if somebody set one of their you know if
they had a tree or something that was
set on fire
they probably don't have a christmas
tree because they're heathens but but
you know if they had something
um if they put out a if they had a big
like unity diversity tree or something
in the in front of their studios and
somebody set that on fire
they would never stop it'd be the only
thing they talked about for the next six
years
we'd get all these like tearful montages
of cnn anchors talking about how
journalism is under attack
this is why we are the the firefighters
for truth literally now our tree is a
flame
uh can you imagine that
the self-murdering that would happen on
cnn
if they were the targets of an attack
like this
speaking of cnn
in fact we don't have to imagine how
they are responding to the uh to the fox
news tree being set on fire uh here is
here's here's how cnn has responded to
it let's watch
obviously it's incredibly scary to feel
that your workplace is under attack
unless
[Applause]
your workplace is the capital then
according to many many fox hosts it's
not such a big deal at fox when the
target is a christmas tree at their
workplace it is a sacrilege but when the
target is the seat of american democracy
it's not
the whole of congress as they certify a
presidential election that was fair and
secure when the perpetrators are trump
supporters in the thousands four of whom
died that day when the victims are
police officers 140 of whom were injured
and when five police officers have died
in the wake of the attack including four
by suicide when fox's own colleagues had
to take cover inside the capitol complex
on january 6 fox down plays the attack
of course bring it back to january 6th
somehow somehow a homeless guy setting
fox news's tree on fire christmas tree
of fire is uh that we can relate that
back to january 6th because everything
goes back to january 6.
um
and and by the way what she just said
there about uh five police officers died
in the wake of the attack
including suicides
this is the left they love doing this
with suicides um
using suicides
as emotional blackmail
and lying about them
they do this on on like every issue
especially the gender issue transition
and they'll straight up lie and they'll
say that uh you know if you if you if
you dare suggest
that only men have penises you are
directly causing people to kill
themselves
and they have no problem doing that
because they're totally soulless
that's what they're doing here i mean
yes there there have been capital police
officers who have tragically committed
suicide since january 6th
but to phrase it that way saying in the
wake of the capital riot uh these
officers committed suicide she is
drawing a direct connection
and and claiming implying
not so subtly that they committed
suicide because of the january 6th riot
because they were you know traumatized
by something there is no evidence of
that there's no indication of that
nobody has come out and said that you
know they wrote a suicide note and they
they indicated that or or
or even that in the lead up to them
committing suicide they were they were
traumatized by the event we haven't
heard anything like that
um
and it seems absence of evidence it's
seen absent of evidence it seems very
unlikely
that these suicides would have anything
to do with the january 6 riot because
there were also riots in 2020 all all
across
the country
and um many of them went on for far
longer than the january 6 riot did and
were far more violent
and i imagine far scarier for the police
involved
and there were no suicides in any of
those cases
so but dave she has no problem just take
a suicide real real human suffering and
use it present it as a as a a pawn a
prop
um
and as far as being a hate crime i mean
going back to what we just talked about
cars why not call it a hate crime why
can't it be
a hate crime
a crime motivated by hate
now it seems in this case that this was
probably just a crazy homeless guy who
doesn't know why he did it probably
doesn't understand any of his
motivations behind anything uh much like
much like the current president united
states
but
if this was done by someone who hates
fox news well that's a crime
motivated by hate
and so but for the for the hate crime
designation which is why the hate crime
designation shouldn't exist
uh the justice system has to say well
yeah i mean it was it was it's a crime
and this person was hateful but
but it's not the kind of hate that we're
worried about
it's completely absurd and as i said
arbitrary
all right
from the daily wire it says simone biles
has been named the times athlete of the
year the same year she won one
individual bronze medal at the tokyo
olympics it's been a tumultuous year for
biles who entered the summer olympics
expected to compete for the gold medal
in each of the five individual events
she was scheduled to participate in she
managed to only successfully complete uh
rather compete in the balance beam
buys toll biles told time at that point
it was no longer about meddling but
about getting back out there
i wanted to compete at the olympics
again and have that experience that i
came for i didn't really care about the
outcome on that beam it was for me
it was all for me she says
forget about team spirit
biles entered the games with uh sky high
expectations after winning four gold
medals in the previous olympics baal was
expected by many to top her rio 2016
numbers by becoming the first american
female gymnast to win five golds at a
single olympics
but then of course as we know she quit
on her team
and um
and now she's been awarded
the time
athlete of the year for quitting
because this is all about mental health
this is about her she says herself you
know the the the one time when she
actually got up on the balance beam and
competed
it wasn't even she's not saying that oh
i had to get out there for my country
it used to be what olympians said they
were they were competing for their
country it's not about me it's about the
country
and in sports that's what you're
that's what we expect and have gotten
used to athletes saying
although that's kind of changing now
but usually they talk about oh no it's
not about individual accolades for me
it's about the team it's about what i'm
representing
[Music]
you know if it's if it's professional
sports it's about my city
and olympics is supposed to be about
your country
but that all changes now and now we're
supposed to celebrate people it's a
total it's a total inversion now uh
things have been
flipped on their head i mean it used to
be as an athlete
if you were obsessively openly
focused on yourself and your individual
accolades
uh
then
that was a shameful thing now we're
supposed to admire it
because we live in a country now
that's run by you know leftist
principles and and leftism is the
worship of the self
and so by by quitting for the sake of
herself and her own mental health or
whatever then it becomes an act of of
heroism according to this religion
all right next things have gotten so bad
in dc that uh these are the kinds of
news reports you might hear
if you live in the city where they are
actually giving tips for preventing
carjacking listen
here in greenbelt we have seen a couple
of violent carjackings in the past week
or so greenbelt police responded to
breeswood court just the other day three
men shot and wound or i should say three
men shot and wounded a man and carjacked
another person at gunpoint in the middle
of the night in order to prevent a
carjacking well here's what we should be
doing police say lock the doors when
driving and when pumping gas in fact
stay in your car if you can at the gas
station always look around before
getting out of your vehicle and if you
are
the victim of a carjacking give up that
car your life is just not worth it equip
your vehicle with an anti-theft or gps
tracking device and allow yourself room
and traffic to move around other cars
avoid getting boxed in if you will and
keep your cell phone in your pocket
rather than laying in your car
for example when you go to a mall or
shopping center
park in a busy area don't park behind a
large truck park where you can be seen
what could you possibly be getting out
of a city that would make this worth it
where you have to strategize like you're
in a war zone
i can't get boxed in got to stay in my
car
what what could pot what about city life
could make that worth it
this is a very real concern you have to
have
you have to have news reports saying hey
if they come for it
if they come for you just uh yeah give
up the car it's not worth it
get out of the city
protect yourself that's the big you know
here's my here's my tip for preventing
carjacking here's my car jacking
prevention tip
uh get out of these kinds of cities
especially any city run by a democrat
get out and of course almost all of them
are so get out of the city and that's
how you prevent the carjackings let's
get out to the comment section
[Music]
hey audience members this is matt walsh
with an incredible app everyone who buys
gas needs to know about get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
in the app store google play right now
use promo code walsh and get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free and use promo code
walsh to get up to 50 cents a gallon
cash back on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making as much as
300 a month in cash back and uh guess
what there's no catch it's very easy you
might be looking for you might be
thinking there's got to be a catch to
something like this they're not just
going to give you free money yes they
will the cash back is added to your
account and it's really as simple as
that you can cash out any time to your
bank account to paypal
you can even cash in for an e gift card
to amazon or other brands
uh why pay
all that money at the pump
and when you could be getting some money
every time you you go to the pump just
download the free get upside app and use
promo code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cash back on your first tank
that's code walsh
george says matt is a monday
day coach about effects of covid
policies authorities make mistakes and
it's easy to condemn them after the fact
monday code you mean monday morning
quarterback is what you're going for
um
about the effects of covet policies
yeah one of the effects like we talked
about yesterday a 51 increase in
adolescent girls going to emergency
rooms after suicide attempts
in 2020 that was one of the effects
am i just monday morning quarterbacking
it you know in retrospect after the fact
hindsight is 2020 that kind of thing
no no this is not a monday morning
quarterback situation george because i
had been i've been saying this from the
very beginning
from the very beginning i've been saying
you lock people in their homes you take
away their social life you take away all
of that especially kids
and you tell them well we're going to
migrate all of that to the internet
and that will be your entire life now
i've been saying from the very beginning
and not just me lots of us have been
saying
you're going to see exactly these
effects
so no this is not after the fact this is
not hindsight it's 20 20.
anyone with a brain had 20 20 vision on
this from the beginning because seeing
where it was going
and our leaders who put these policies
in place they knew also it's just they
didn't care is the point
it was a trade-off it was always going
to be a trade-off
that's not how they sold it
they sold it as sort of a better safe
than sorry situation
and um and how you know
staying home locking down shutting
everything down
at most it's just an inconvenience
wearing masks at most is just an
inconvenience that's all it is
a little bit of effort
but that was always clearly bogus
there's a there's a very real trade-off
happening here
many trade-offs and one of them is
we are going to for the sake of the
physical safety
that these measures supposedly afforded
us supposedly
we are going to sacrifice the
psychological and emotional well-being
of our kids
that was the trade that they
intentionally made
and this is the result
um
guy greens says sorry matt but i like
the hodge twins children's book better
walruses creep me out with their weird
eyes well what do you think's gonna
happen when you come into my comments
with this kind of anti-wall racism
weird eyes they have beautiful and and
innocent eyes
and now i'm the bad guy because i have
to ban you
don't put me in that position but you
are banned
um
bad mother says matt walsh making small
talk with people in a jiffy lube seems
unlikely well that is true i mean you
know
without without phones if i'm sitting in
a waiting room or something
if we didn't have phones yeah i wouldn't
be making small talk with people
but even so
and if i'm saying this then you know
it's gotten really bad
but
even if i wouldn't make small talk with
people
i think it's still best to just be
present sometimes in the room where
you're sitting
even if you're not saying anything to
anybody
to be to be present in the room and not
on your phone
and aware that you i am physically in
this room with these people
and we are having a shared experience
might not be a very profound experience
but it that's that's what it is
um we don't have those kinds of uh
there's there's no presence any any
anymore anywhere because everybody's on
their phone and there are really no
shared experiences anymore
matthew kelly says after watching your
last episode particularly the
cancellation of uh those involved in
civil asset forfeiture i must say that i
feel personally attacked i am actually a
prosecutor that handles all of the civil
asset forfeiture cases for my office
when i determine whether we'll be moving
to take in a vehicle money or even a
house i carefully review the initial
reports to see whether the seized
property was either used in furtherance
of criminal activity or or were proceeds
from criminal activity the main goal is
not to enrich the state but rather take
money slash property gained through
illicit means so that it does not return
to the defendant permitting them a
profit from their criminal activity if
it later turns out that the criminal
portion of the case falls apart and thus
a civil forfeiture action cannot survive
i make arrangements to have the money
property slash property returned to the
claimant slash defendant all property
must be substantiated i understand a
layman's gripe about the concept of
civil asset forfeiture but please
understand that there are legitimate and
good reasons for the process
yeah um so
what i'm taking from this
matthew is that
what i take from this is that you are
responsible and honest person
and as a responsible and honest person
you handle this power that you've been
given civil asset forfeiture responsibly
and honestly
which is nice and that's that's a credit
to you but it's still a power you
shouldn't have
because many prosecutors are not
responsible and honest
and our system cannot assume that they
will be
and that's what all of the protections
in the constitution
for
uh defendants or those accused
all of those all those protections
that's why they're there
because we can't simply
assume
that law enforcement and and da's and
prosecutors and everything they're all
going to be like matthew kelly they're
all going to be honest
i mean if we could assume that then we
wouldn't need due process we wouldn't
need any of this stuff
the fact remains a civil asset
forfeiture now i don't know how you
you might do it in your office
differently
but the laws as they're written
and we talked about one real-life case
that just happened down in dallas
the laws as they're written mean that
this property can be
confiscated
without without even without it without
a crime being charged
or without the person who is the victim
here even being accused of a crime
so this is not the way you're putting it
forward here it sounds like well there's
a there's an evidentiary process you
have to be charged with a crime there's
this whole thing that's not what
happened in the in the uh dallas there
was a love field airport
somebody tried to
to go through the airport
flying domestically okay so they weren't
coming across the border or anything
like that tried to uh tried to they just
flew from i think it was chicago to
dallas
and they had a bunch of cash in their
luggage which is not a crime
and the police took it right there on
the spot
didn't charge the other the person with
a crime
not formally accusing them of doing
anything
but they take the property anyway
which i think is clearly um
not acceptable and it is
by definition a
violation of the due process clause the
constitution we know that the biden's
administration the bite administration's
unconstitutional vaccine mandate is not
doing well in court so far not only has
the osha mandate received a nationwide
stay the u.s senate has just voted 48-52
against biden's federal mandate however
the the issue now goes to the
democrat-led house will likely push it
through this is why we can't leave such
a contentious issue up to those in the
highest echelons of the government and
have taken matters uh into our own hands
the daily wire was the first in the
nation to file suit against biden's
authoritarian mandate and there will be
many more to come the onus is on us the
people to continue to fight back when
they try to force our compliance because
what we put in our bodies is not up to
the government and neither is how we
spend our holidays which uh biden's
winter coveted plan hinted at doing the
plan includes the extension the federal
mass mandate for public transportation
as well as a consideration anyway they
might require uh vaccines to fly even
domestically
so that's what at stake here our
collective voices have never been more
important in the fight for our freedom
and now is your chance to add your voice
to the fight if you haven't signed our
petition against biden's vaccine mandate
i need you to head on over to
dailywire.com do not comply to add your
name uh we need to send an overwhelming
message to this administration that the
american people will not comply we have
a goal of reaching one million
signatures which would provide a major
boost to our legal challenge we have
nearly 800 000 signatures so far we want
to get to a million so to add your voice
to this and get us to a million
signatures and that's when they really
have to take no note of it go to
dailywire.com
do not comply
and
this is my opportunity to tell you about
uh i'll have more to say about this in
just a second we get into daily
cancellation but uh johnny the walrus my
uh best-selling lgbt children's book is
currently still on sale and um you can
go to johnnythewalrus.com to buy it
this is uh if you want to know the
sensation that everyone's been talking
about what all the controversy is about
well you could buy it for yourself uh we
are we sold out of our first we sold out
in a day as you've heard but we are
taking pre-orders for the next batch
when they come so go to johnnywalrus.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
now you all know that normally i like to
have
fun on this show as much fun as i am
constitutionally capable of having
anyway which isn't much so never mind
the point is that today i have to get
very serious and um
even a little emotional perhaps
you probably remember that i began this
week in a state of elation deeply proud
of the fact that my children's book
johnny the walrus about a boy who
identifies as a walrus had not only
become one of the top five best-selling
books on amazon but it also made it onto
amazon's lgbt book list where it was
number one
my walrus novel had had only been on
sale for a few days but already it was
the most popular piece of lgbt
literature in the world
topping the list and beating out such
lgbt titles as filthy bromance and um
holigay and daddy's little christmas
these are all real titles by the way
even it even bested the classic sexted
by santa thrust into love book four
they probably should have stuck with
sexted by santa trilogy you know the
narrative really lost its momentum in
the fourth installment some critics are
reporting anyway
um kind of a kind of a naked cash grab
in more ways than one you might say but
in any case
i had suddenly become the most prominent
influential celebrated and revered lgbt
voice in the world and possibly in all
of history i didn't expect to be put in
that position but i was ready to fulfill
the responsibilities of that office
faithfully
i had big plans for the lgbt movement of
which i was now the sole and
unquestioned leader
yes it's true that i am heterosexual but
there's no reason why
that should should exclude me from
holding this title
i am a straight lgbt author
and leader
and walrus awareness advocate
these are all parts of my complex and
intersectional identity i am an enigma
even to myself
my identity is a vast mosaic of
different elements and pieces all adding
up to one beautiful yet complicated
whole and from these mysterious depths
spraying forth the work of tortured
genius
known as johnny the walrus
does all this sound extremely
narcissistic and nonsensical perhaps
but that only again proves why i deserve
to be the voice of the lgbt movement
which is what i am
yet in an act of mutiny
and treason
my fellow lgbt activists turned on me
they complained bitterly about the fact
that my book was on the lgbt charts
they were envious
indeed they didn't want it on any charts
at all i reported yesterday that media
matters had published a hit piece
accusing me of transphobia and other
assorted thought crimes glad the gay and
lesbian alliance against defamation
aligned itself with my defamers
calling on amazon to remove the book
from the lgbt category
other activists chimed in some of them
tagging jeff bezos calling on amazon's
founder to address the matter personally
in the greatest act of betrayal my
favorite website
the gay news site pink news published an
article with this title
right-wing pundit gloats as amazon lists
hateful transphobic book as lgbt plus
bestseller
the article explains
amazon has listed a hateful transphobic
children's book by the daily wires matt
walsh as its number one best-selling
lgbt book walsh a right-wing writer who
has compared gender-affirming healthcare
to experimentation molestation abuse and
rape recently announced that he has
written a horrific
horrific anti-trans children's book
johnny the walrus set to be published in
march
the book began taking pre-orders this
month on amazon which is inexp inexc
inexplicably classed it as an lgbt book
in review the right-wing publication the
blaze said matt walsh's work is an
effort to push back against radical
gender ideology which defies biological
reality
but if anything says ideology surely
it's a book that tells children that
expressing their gender means being
forced to eat worms and having their
feet cut off
johnny the walrus supposedly aimed at
three to five-year-olds tells the story
of a little boy who pretends to be a
walrus johnny's mother is pressured by
the internet to tell her child that he
is a walrus and protesters are shown
with signs claiming human walruses are
real walruses the most twisted attack on
trans kids is when johnny's mom takes
him to the doctor who tells him he must
only eat worms constantly wear itchy
gray makeup and have his feet cut into
fins
now for the record
if that part of the story is an attack
on anyone it would be an attack on
people who mutilate kids not on the kids
themselves obviously this is like if
you're punching somebody in the face and
i tell you to stop and you accuse me of
attacking the person that you were
punching so you're the attacker in that
situation i am the intervener in the
attack that's how that relationship
works
but anyway the greater point here
is that the very people who ought to
have been coming to my aid and defending
me as a straight gay icon
were instead focused on marginalizing me
and their campaign of hate and bigotry i
am sad to report has worked
this morning i awoke to discover
that johnny the walrus the most
courageous piece of lgbt literature ever
written has been removed from amazon's
lgbt bestseller list they took it off
no explanation
they didn't ask me
i didn't consent
and it's not just that there that there
had been a surge and sexted by santa
sales supplanting my book as number one
if that were the case i would tip my cap
to the sexting santa and accept defeat
but that's not what happened
i was removed from the category entirely
i have been literally erased
i've been targeted for violence not
literal violence but literary violence
jesse smallett was not the victim of an
anti-gay hate crime but i am
i'm also a better fiction writer
incidentally
this is an attack not just on on on me
but on the whole lgbt community and on
the walrus community
i feel i have to say deeply
afraid now
unsafe
i mean if i cannot be safe and secure on
the amazon lgbt list then where can i
turn
where am i safe
i have represented and defended the lgbt
community faithfully for these many
hours
who will defend me now
no one i feel alone
and cold
and abandoned
but i have cried all the tears uh i can
cry over this i'm sure there'll be many
tears in the future
i have been dehumanized delegitimized
decertified vaporized
but i'm not gonna back down
i'm still gonna stand up and be loud and
proud and speak my truth
a truth which is grounded in my lived
experience as an lgbt author and walrus
advocate
amazon can't stop me nobody can
i'm not going to be canceled instead to
glaad and pink news and amazon and media
matters with all the strength i can
muster as a best-selling lgbt author a
title i will retain forever by the way i
say that you all
are canceled
shame on you
shame on you
i told you we get a little bit emotional
to close out of friday
but i had to i had to be vulnerable with
you and i and i hope that's that's okay
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching
thanks for listening make sure to buy my
book johnnywalrus.com
talk to you monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin